there are shocking new images of
migrants packed inside a tractor-trailer
on the mexican side of the u.s border
and it's highlighting the dangers of
illegal immigration customs and border
protection say the truck carrying 150
people was stopped by mexican
authorities before it entered the state
of texas u.s officials recently
announced they have apprehended a record
number of migrants this year emanuel
manuel bohorkas whose name is not chains
joins us now from near the border in
laredo texas with more on that part of
the story manny good morning to you
good morning gail nearly half of the
people apprehended by border patrol this
fiscal year have been sent back due to a
trump era pandemic policy known as title
42 it prohibits migrants from entering
the u.s due to the danger of
communicable disease but we spoke with
many people who have qualified to
proceed with a case of asylum in this
country and we got a firsthand look at
their relocation
process you can see
shoes
bags
water bottles clearly this is a route
for asylum seekers yes this is normally
a route that they take walking along the
southern border with maverick county
deputy sheriff denise cantu migrant
crossings show no sign of stopping you
see they even have a sign for them where
it's a sigal camino so they pretty much
guide them
to where they can just you know
gather gather all of them and pick them
up the sign means follow the path and
deputy cantu says it's evidence of just
how normal border crossings have become
law enforcement has already tallied more
than 1.9 million migrant encounters this
fiscal year breaking the record said
last year with two months left to go
after they're processed at the border
some asylum seekers arrive at facilities
like this one in del rio texas about an
hour away
it's a pit stop as they await buses to
their next destinations like edison
gutierrez from venezuela who has his
written down midland texas another
venezuelan angie cordero and her
ten-year-old daughter know what they
left behind
the hunger
where god takes you since april texas
has sent nearly 8 thousand migrants to
washington d.c and new york city a move
those cities mayors have called inhumane
texas emergency management chief insists
otherwise some have
have claimed or tried to accuse that we
are putting people on these buses and we
are holding them hostage and making them
go to a final destination that is
exactly not true
the state's division of emergency
management says migrants head to d.c and
new york only if they've opted in and
signed waivers otherwise the federal
government partners with local
organizations to help migrants arrange
alternative plans
some of them have a destination
midland texas for example but others
told us they didn't know where to go
what happens to them well in order to go
through border patrol processing they
have to have some sort of destination
some sort of idea
because that's part of their paperwork
tiffany burrow runs the del rio migrant
center and told us the state's east
coast bussing program provides another
option for asylum seekers as they
continue to cross the southern border
the volume
is more than than anyone could possibly
imagine
borough told us last month they had more
than six thousand migrants come through
that facility in del rio texas that's
more than they've ever seen and of
course all of this comes with a price
tag the texas emergency management chief
told us the state has already spent
about 12 million dollars on the bus
program to new york and d.c vlad
it's a difficult story uh manny but when
you hear a ten-year-old and her mom
saying they're leaving behind the hunger
your heart goes to them thank you very
much manny